good afternoon good evening whatever
time of the day it is that you're
watching uh this latest edition of down
the middle
we have jim chanos with us today uh he's
founder of kinecos associates an
investment firm and arguably arguably
the world's preeminent short seller
and that means for anybody who's
unfamiliar with the idea of short
selling in general that means you you
profit when prices decline
um jim welcome
thanks for having me danielle
before we get into
kind of what you do and what inspired
you to do what you do
uh can we talk a little bit about art
because i'm i'm a big fan i've got a
cousin in new york who's got the largest
private collection of drawings in the
country so i'm curious what kind of art
interests you such that the bbc did an
entire documentary the banker's guide to
art
that was a long time ago um so well i've
been a collector since pretty much the
uh the late 80s early 90s
um and i'm kind of on two ends of the
spectrum uh contemporary art on one end
which is what i think the bbc was
interested in
uh and then um some some uh ancient uh
ancient pieces from the ancient world um
so uh i'm kind of literally on both ends
of the the spectrum
but uh but i haven't been buying
anything now for a number of years it's
the market like a lot of asset markets
has just gotten kind of crazy
i bet it has uh presumably some of the
ancient art has come from from greece
uh yeah well of course providence is
always an issue there so be very careful
that you're you know legally acquiring
anything um but yes mostly mostly greek
and roman interesting um so you are i'm
i'm i'm the product of italian
immigrants uh you're you're the talent
you're the product of greek immigrants
your parents were first generation i
believe
uh well my mother was uh mary catherine
sullivan so she was quite irish but my
father my father was first generation
greek american
and i'm i'm curious so i'm i'm almost
more curious about your mom but i'm
going to ask about both
uh so milwaukee this is where you grew
up
it was and and your mother was an office
manager for a a steel company a steel
mill
what was
what was it like growing up in the rust
belt before it was rusty and what what
was manufacturing in america when you
grew up
so i i like to to talk about like sort
of the the tug of war the pendulum
between capital and labor and the story
i tell is that um
in the summers of 1978 and 79 i got a
job working in steel mill uh in
milwaukee uh for babcock and wilcox
which was owned by inland inland steel
at the time my mother worked for inland
steel and i had to join the union and i
was a proud member of boilermakers and
pipefitters union until the early 90s
but i was making the equivalent of 14 an
hour in 1979
and basically for two months out of out
of each year i paid for my college
education uh by working on union job in
steel
but that that was the peak right that
was the peak in the american labor
movement we saw the election of thatcher
that year in the uk and reagan in uh in
the u.s sure and the pendulum which had
gone from from post to the depression uh
increased keynesian increased status
um you know reliance on labor began to
move the other way toward uh sort of
preference for capital and and my job in
1978-79 is the perfect sort of microcosm
of that
that's fascinating i worked in a steel
mill i worked for a steel company in
caracas uh earlier on in my life and it
was interesting to watch
china's increasing influence
in that arena in in venezuela this is
prior to chavez coming on uh but but
manufacturing it certainly has changed
worldwide uh since since 1978 1979
sure has well i worked on uh so the the
the mill i was at made tubular steel and
we we had two basic end markets we had
uh
the drilling business which was going
great guns uh in in the late 70s
and we also made reinforced pipes for
nuclear power plants
and i remember being at school
in the spring during that period 78 or
79 i guess it was 79
and the three-mile island incident
occurred and walter cronkite very
somberly said that you know and the uh
the piping was made by babcock and
wilcox and i turned around to everybody
in the tv room in our college tv room
and said hey i worked on those bikes oh
gosh
oh my gosh
yeah
it's a little little uh little um
interesting side though i'm i will never
freak i i will always associate you now
with three mile island don't take that
the wrong way
um
you know i i also want to talk about the
idea of and i'm jumping ahead here but
your father ran
uh
a chain of dry cleaners
and it was a family bit it was a family
business with his two brothers so
services in america um
how you know inflation in services how
we i mean during during the coronavirus
i think it was 12 months between the
time that i made
one trip to the to the next to the dry
cleaners uh
what what what are your views on on how
americans
back then consume services and how they
consume them now i know these are
off-ball questions but i'm just curious
because of your background you you have
to have some perspective on these things
well yeah i mean obviously uh
the way
services uh some services are are
consumed and deliberate has changed
dramatically uh you know i i would bet
that uh
back then people actually came to the
dry cleaners to drop off their clothes
right and and uh
and i think we had a a
for a handful of years a premium
delivery service that we charged that
nobody basically used um you know and
today i think that that's completely
different convenience
matters uh services and goods are often
just simply delivered to your door
um and and so
obviously the the
and the whole idea of small businesses
being able to make it when up against
any sort of larger corporate entity that
can do this
i i'm not sure if walmart's still doing
to pick up dry cleaning but i bet they
are and uh
and so you know
that has changed the way we looked at
lots of
small service businesses that probably
flourished in the 60s and 70s
that have seen probably a real slow
decline in in the last few decades
and especially in the last two years um
of course which is a shame um
so i i'm curious so you're at the
university of wisconsin right now um
and and you are
you teach students today about about
financial fraud
how
how does that
carry over
with a younger cohort of students who
think that maybe markets only go up
because they've been born into an era of
endless fed liquidity
so uh so first of all i want to clarify
for for the viewers that it's it's a
it's a course on how to identify
financial fraud using a historical there
about how to commit it um
so
we want to be pretty clear about that um
so yeah the course of wisconsin is uh is
uh the same course i teach at yale
and it's it's become a pretty popular
course but but it's for mba students
typically second year mba students
it's an elective at both schools
uh but i think there's still some
fascination with the dark side of
business
i do i do point out to to my students
that that you know almost no matter what
they do
whether it's in finance or directly in
business or even in the nonprofit arena
you know fraud will probably touch their
their professional life at some point
and and how to identify it uh and and
and you know uh warn or insulate um
the effects of it is is probably an
increasingly important skill that's
number one
um
number two for those of my students that
are more financially oriented you know i
make the strong point that the fraud
cycle follows the business and financial
cycle but with a lag
so when you get these
really really long
and and then also bull markets people's
sense of disbelief begins to erode
that's a point of maximum peril for uh
for investors and a maximum opportunity
for fraudsters so you know that's why we
saw the wave of fraud after the dot-com
era
and and probably right now as well i've
called this the golden age of fraud but
but students are generally
correctly
taught to emulate success via the case
method and instruction
um but it's also important to alert them
to signals as i say to the dark side
of of the business world because it is
there it's it's significant uh and it
has the disproportionate uh impact uh
through externalities and other other
mechanisms
so um
come back to the fed for a minute only
in the sense that fed policy has clearly
elongated cycles
uh so is it in in these types of
environments when liquidity is so flush
and liquidity is presumably flowing to
companies that aren't that don't merit
it is it more difficult in this
environment to uncover uh to uncover
fraud at companies
well i mean you could point it out um
and on an isolated basis like the
valiants and wire cards of the world you
know it it still can it still can unwind
but when you have ample liquidity and we
have a macro model that we use as one of
our five systematic models that i teach
about
the concept of fraud and and the macro
model
by kendall berger and minsky really has
as one of its its
uh tenants credit creation and easy
money
um that's a very fertile area for for
fraud to to uh to grow it and so
obviously we have that now
um you have the idea of central bank
puts throughout the markets whether it's
equities or others
that again enable people to think well
generally even even if someone's not
telling me the truth i'll be okay um and
and so
it's we're in that part of the phase of
the cycle that people just are believing
pretty much anything
that people tell them because it's
worked
well and we also had the fed step in and
backstop the corporate bond market uh
you know when you were just 26 years old
you started off uh
analyzing the junk bonds at uh at drexel
burnham and now that market is in excess
of of three trillion dollars if you add
up high yield bonds and leverage loans
uh
does any of this make sense in terms of
the magnitude that we're seeing
well only to the extent it's probably
controlled by one person today like it
was back then
uh you know back uh back then it was
mike milken today it's jay powell
wow that's a
powerful thing i mean i i just think
that that um
look as you you point out i mean the fed
has expanded its mandate and you know
better than almost anyone you know we
now have we have three things stool
right it's it's it's uh
inflation it's employment and its uh
asset prices
and you know now that we've added asset
prices implicitly to the mix
um you really have you really have a
witch's brew
because investors are are now clearly uh
counting on it and i should go back to
the dot com error which this this era
resembles the most to me
obviously every every every cycle is
different but um
you know the muscle memory dot com era
is is still pretty strong with me and
and we forget that that there was a fed
concept of a fed put the whole idea of
the fed put
um
was was evident back then and really
kicked in
when the fed aggressively uh reversed
its course and began easing after ltcm
in october of 98 yep
and and and that
that about face
really kicked things off for for the
rest of uh 98 all of 99 in the first
quarter of 2000
where basically people said look anytime
the markets are going to go down and
they went down about 20 percent in the
in september october of 98
the fed has our back and i go back to
not the pandemic but i go back to the
fourth quarter of 2018.
as the fed was was slowly tightening
um the markets finally you know had a
puke moment we're down 20 percent the
fourth quarter
and uh and the fed blinked and they they
aggressively reversed course this is a
year before the pandemic
um and so i i think that that since that
moment since that that christmas of
night of uh of 18 you know
investors have really been emboldened by
by the fact that the central banks won't
let them lose money
so i'm curious because what set that
what set that process off or at least
the very culmination of that process was
when the debt of general electric was
downgraded uh on halloween in in 2018
and then 14 days later junk bond
issuance froze solid and the the
phenomena was the credit market bleeding
into the stock market and i'm curious
and i truly don't
even begin to have an
answer to this
how is it feasible or possible or not to
try and benefit from overvalued
corporate bonds yeah i mean
corporate we we've been short uh over
our our career uh you know all kinds of
corporate debt down through the years
and what what's what's interesting is
that then it has often an asymmetric
you know risk reward because uh if
you're shorting
uh credit that's about to be impaired uh
near par you kind of know uh other than
the coupon what your price risk is
um you're not gonna really go above
power at maturity um so that's
interesting the problem of course is
liquidity and borrow
um you're often much more subject to
agency risk when you're shorting
corporate debt
um because there are fewer holders than
a widely held equity
um and and so you know bonds can be
called back it it gets a lot trickier
and that's one of the reasons why the
cds market grew so rapidly among other
reasons um you know 10 20 years ago
but
but you know now the fed is clearly
buying you know corporate debt um
and and that's obviously made that that
game you know a lot more difficult as
well
well so um
so
let's get let's get into a little bit of
the history of of your shorting and
my question is
what is the favorite short of yours in
your history that no one asks you about
that's a great question um
i mean we were we were
we were very proud of of our work that
we did in the junk bond area to kind of
complete the theme
um on drexel back in the mid 80s
and what what made drexel so interesting
to me was not only the companies that
milken was was
financing
but the fact that he was engaged in this
amazing regulatory arbitrage
that nobody figured out and and
if you went back and looked a lot of the
corporate raiders that milken financed
uh had regulated uh the financial
subsidiaries in their complex that they
they you know they took in deposits
whether it was an insurance company like
first executive or a trust company or
columbia savings and loan the charlie
keating's lincoln savings and low oh my
gosh yes continental and and
you know the rules are you can't
dividend money up from regulated
financial subsidiaries without approval
and without profitability
and so these these entities had billions
and billions of dollars of cash and
securities
that the raiders really couldn't get
their hands on
but milken figured out a way to be able
to do that and and he had them each buy
each other's parent company debt
and as long as he could kind of control
that flow
um you know company a with an snl would
buy company b parents debt in the s l
and then uh when it became time for
company a parent to issue debt company
b's insurance subsidiary would buy a
company a's parent debt
and it was a way to basically upstream
money out of regulated subs it was
genius
and nobody ever figured that out
um and and uh
and so it's also why the drexel collapse
had much more systemic impact than you
would think
because the daisy chain had dominoes
embedded in it once the dominoes started
to fall the capital got impaired in all
these leveraged financial subsidiaries
so that was that was some work that i
think that we did that was not only kind
of profitable but but important
um
and then again you know everybody of
course remembers enron but we probably
made a lot more money
uh in the 2000 to 02 time period
on uh on things like lucent and worldcom
and some of the big leveraged telecom
plays
um some were fraud some were not but but
almost all of them collapsed
because of the telecom bubble and and
i i'm
it's important to note i'm saying
telecom bubble not internet bubble um
and i think that that area was uh
was important and then the other thing
that that in our history that you might
find interesting
that i don't think you know uh
ever gets much attention
is uh is the warning uh at the g7
meeting in april of 07 that paul singer
and i gave to the
the world's central bankers and uh and
treasury ministry and finance ministers
um we were asked by bob steele
to make a presentation at the washington
g7 finance ministers meeting
because at the time the germans were
making lots of noises about hedge funds
uh as locusts
and um
paul and i
gave separate but but kind of
interlinked presentations on the risks
of structured finance and just how much
structured finance and derivatives were
at regulated banks
and brokers
in the g7
and um
you know it was uh everybody was in the
room i mean
gordon brown was in the room mario
draghi was in the room the fred was
there i mean it was everybody and i
always laugh when when people say well
nobody you know
no one issued warnings or no one
whatever i was literally in the room
issuing the warning
um
with all these uh people in the spring
of 07. because if you remember the abx
had already collapsed in the first
quarter of 07
and we had gotten financial information
on the banks of brokers at year end 06
of their holdings of so-called level 1
level 2 and level 3 securities and it
became very clear
that a number of systemically important
institutions held massive amounts of
level 2 and level 3
securities
many of them of course in the
residential mortgage
arena and it didn't take a rocket
scientist to just take a look at what
the abx had done and
magnify that on the level three holdings
um for the big banks and brokers and
realized that most of them were
insolvent and boy did we ever i mean
i'll never forget having to having to
google landis bank because i had no i
had no idea what a german landis bank
was all i know is that that was one of
the first bombs that went on three
months yeah that was three months later
danielle followed by northern rock
that's absolutely right i mean gosh that
takes me back
um
let's talk about
let's talk about china a little bit um
you know china
has had a long-standing goal of
westernizing their economy making it
less industrial making it more domestic
consumption
focused and it seems as if they might
have pressed the button on the property
market a little too hard and now they
find themselves
buried in unimaginable amounts of debt
and
your average chinese household is
spending double
that of what your average u.s household
is spending on for housing so they don't
have as much money to to to consume the
other things that that the chinese
authorities want for them to consume but
my question is
how was how how did how did something of
this magnitude which you identified
how has it been so prolonged why is it
just now that we're seeing
starting obviously with evergrand but
clearly there they look like domino's
falling
yeah uh but we'll see this is so this is
the fourth
uh instance since we've been when kind
of warning about china at the end of o
nine this is the fourth instance now
where the the the party has tried to
reign in specifically
um leverage and real estate um
development and it and in each of the
three previous times the government has
blinked and i'm guessing we're in the
process of blinking again
because each and every time the economy
you know forgetting the
the country's stated numbers uh the the
country's economy wanted to stall speed
pretty quickly
and they panicked
and and so it's it's just endemic to the
model and i've called it the treadmill
to hell
because
when you have investment at almost 50
percent of your gdp which is
unprecedented
um year in and year out
the good news is i've joked you know
your annual gdp on january 1 of that
year because you literally can plan it
the problem of course is if you never
write anything off
you're deceiving yourself because you're
simply putting up structures that are
uneconomic or empty just so you can
print a gdp number
and it means that you'll you're never
going to get consumption
to grow up because you know as i
remember from my macroeconomics class
50 years ago is you know i equals s
so if you have a view of an economic
model based on i
you have to have the s and and
and and so savings rates have to equal
the massive amounts of concrete they're
pouring everywhere you know in china so
when we started looking at china
investment was 46 of gdp
i think last year it might have dipped
down to 43 or 44 as i recall
but i mean meaningfully it hasn't
changed in in 12 years
consumption was i think 33 or 34 now
it's 37. it's up a little bit
but but make no mistake about it the
chinese economic model is based on
construction and specifically
construction of of high rises and mostly
apartment buildings
and and
china builds 20 million flats a year
whether they need them or not
and residential real estate we think is
about 20 percent of gdp residential real
estate construction
and i i saw ken rogoff's numbers that
he's probably in the ballpark that all
real estate activities are about 30
wow
of gdp and these are just staggering
these these dwarf japan in 89 this dwarf
spain and ireland and o6 i mean these
are literally off the charts kind of
numbers
and uh
yeah i mean i it's going to be one of
the great questions of
the next 10 years is how do they get
themselves off this
this model
well i mean i i obviously i think we're
going to find out and we know that we
know that their fourth quarter might see
a 5 print
allowed by authorities so i mean that i
mean i feel like we've
run full circle through the fastest
economic cycle i've ever seen because
we're seeing so many late cycle
indicators and we're back to talking
about china being at a 30-year low
growth rate so it it this is deja vu
within 18 months i've never seen
cycle compression
like i have and it really doesn't feel
like this flash recession that we had
for two months here in the united states
it doesn't feel like it it doesn't feel
like there was a bear market there
well there really wasn't i mean it was
up three weeks four weeks
and there was price movement but it was
not prolonged then it was a v-shape you
know recovery in the markets
again thanks to to you know perceptions
of central bank liquidity and um
and a pretty pretty aggressive fiscal
stimulus but china's you know china is a
different animal because the they're
they are they're operating under
different drivers and so um
it really is i mean i i
they're gonna they're now talking about
gearing up infrastructure spending again
to offset private you know
construction
and i'm just laughing to myself because
you know when i started looking at china
as an example the island of hainan which
is sort of their tropical resort island
in the south china sea had one
international airport
you know since then it is it has
designed and built the second
international airport and now it's
talking about a third international
airport all in the last 10 years and the
first one was a necessity the second one
was a luxury
but the third one is probably folly
and and yet all of them will contribute
to gdp by just simply being built
so
yeah this is this is uh this is an
unprecedented experiment in
macroeconomic policy and i really don't
think it gets even the attention even
with evergreen that it deserves because
running investment in half of your
economy for you know decades
is is just you know
like nothing we've ever seen yeah i'll
never forget a statistic that i i saw
maybe 12 months ago or so to your point
that there were 30 airports in china
either being
updated or under full-blown construction
and i'm saying to myself who's going to
fly into all these airports
and
it's just
and even if they do will they be
economic i mean will they even earn
their costs right and and that's the
real problem you know same thing with
high-speed rail everyone loves it looks
great it's very modern
but there's no return on the investment
and the debt against it
so
that's why you you and it gets to
another problem with china and that is
debt in the banking system and china is
still a bank-centric
system
you know is still growing at 2x gdp and
and it's down from 3x gdp 10 years ago
but
2x gdp will still kill you
um you know the assets in the banking
system um year over year recently have
been growing you know somewhere in the
low teens about 12 percent
and uh and so that compounding
you know starts to get you and also
tells you that probably a lot of those
loans that are being extended are simply
ponzi finance they're they're just loans
extended to keep the old loans current
yes i'll never forget hearing that that
china had up up and created a municipal
bond market
simply because they needed a receptacle
a place to put more debt a place to move
the money around to so
uh but but i'm wondering if you have any
views on the wealth destruction and xi
jinping and his his future and whether
or not he's going to survive what's
happening right now there are rumblings
starting to come out of china that he's
gone a little bit too far
in trying to rein in
some of the successes of individuals
yeah i i
i've heard those rumblings too but i
would short them because
uh the one thing that that we have seen
with his rise in 2012 and 2013
is that he was a new type he was
basically i should say an old school
kind of chinese leader um and the first
the first speech he gave as president as
party secretary
was a speech to the party faithful
um saying that uh uh that gorbachev uh
should have
struck down perestroika when he had the
chance the soviets had aired and the the
chinese set up an institute for the
study of the soviet collapse
um after schnitzel paint got in in
office
so xi jinping was the only uh major
world leader who attended uh putin's
games winter games in sochi
um and he's he's really identified with
authoritarianism
and one-man rule far greater than his
his predecessors going back to either
deng xiaoping or mao zedong
and you know we clearly got indications
that he did not intend to uh relinquish
power
when the second of his terms is up next
year
um
so i've i've you know i've heard lots of
things particularly from always the
business community
that oh uh uh xu xingping is going to be
reigned in
uh he's he has to you know deal with
other factions
and i would completely
discount those i think xi jinping
has done nothing but strengthen
his uh hold on power
i think that he's clearly now decided
on a different strategy regarding the
embracing of capitalism you've been
warned
uh they they are very clear one thing
the chinese communist party does do
is tell you what it's going to do and
they are telling you what they're going
to do they're going to increase taxes
they're going to restrict the power of
celebrity ceos
um there's going to be less impact on
less
emphasis on the 1
and more on the 99
and you ignore that at your own peril as
a western investor
so um speaking of power bases uh
let's shift gears and come back to the
united states uh
my former employer right now the federal
reserve there seems to be quite the
power struggle
going on um
what what are your views on
it
well is there anything that can that can
halt the momentum when you combine the
three powers of passive investing
with
fed liquidity with shareholder buybacks
is there anything that can derail this
momentum that seems to have truly taken
on a life of its own
well i would i would argue
i would argue that the last one is
questionable because although share
buybacks
are have come back somewhat they're
pretty focused in on high-end companies
and what what what we are seeing is the
difference and i've always joked
you have to remember that wall street
has a printing press too
it just takes a little while to get it
coiled up
and wall street really since the
beginning part of 2021
um has been issuing all kinds of stuff
particularly the equity markets
whether it was the spac boom of the
first quarter
uh or the ipo boom we're in now i mean
we're gonna break records for equity
issuance this year
and coupled with insider selling
um i think that in my world anyway um
we're just seeing lots of supply right
now and uh and then of course you have
uh the advent of the retail investor
which i think is the other big story
um and and the advent of you know just
an embracing of speculation whether it's
in
uh stocks or cryptocurrencies or
whatever have you
um and undoubtedly that's something
that's that's new in the past couple of
years so as the market has gone higher
and higher and higher we've gotten
uh quite frankly fewer more and more
unsophisticated investors
um
who are chasing things that
kind of
you know
uh almost unprecedented prices
so uh it looks like it looks like the
fed's going to be forced to uh to taper
its purchases it looks like we're not
going to get
appreciably the same size of fiscal
support and i'm talking about direct
money direct to individuals
you know stimulus checks unemployment
benefits uh supplemental
is is it going to make a difference when
the fed starts to tamp on the brakes and
and do they have to because the
difference between now and
the financial crisis is
inflation well i mean so so let's let's
talk about that a little bit i mean you
know the the goal of fed policy has been
to get inflation and now that we we
ostensibly have it
um they're telling you well don't worry
because it's transitory um
and and so
all right there's that little conundrum
um and then of course there's the the
concept of
investors who have have basically
applauded the central banks and have
said okay
well that liquidity is there and is is
bolstering valuations and risk-taking
um will effortlessly for the most part
tell you why that
that liquidity being taken away is not
bearish because it indicates a robust
economy or take your pick
so of course investors will always find
the glass half full explanation on all
this and that's fine
but
sometimes the logic that speaks to me uh
in terms of uh
what policy does change
uh look the question before and you're
you know you're a fed watcher i'm not
um
is you know are they are they going down
the road to making a policy error right
are they just staying too easy
too long
and where we're going to get a for the
first time what they really wanted which
is a you know an inflationary cycle
going
and i don't know i mean i i just
that's above my pay grade but
um clearly
the amazing amounts of uh support via qe
and ultra low rates
uh you know we're probably at a at a
inflection point again
does does it matter to the markets who
is running the fed i mean they're
dropping like flies
uh
i mean what would a change in leadership
be a market moving event and or
if you had your choice outside of the
usual suspects who do you think the
market would
welcome
uh to run the federal reserve i mean
there's i mean it's it's pretty apparent
by looking at the betting that it's not
necessarily one or the other
two are who are in the main role
unless paul volcker were to show up
again
i don't think the market really cared i
think i think the market correctly
assumes they're all dovish
got it well and so you know and so
that's what we had you know from the
late 60s to late 70s and and
everybody was afraid to really you know
put the put the the inflationary
uh uh
structure back the
genie back in the bottle until volcker
showed up and so
um i don't see anybody on the current
list that strikes me as as
you know particularly hawkish uh so i
suspect the markets really think the
same thing they think they pretty much
think it's going to be business as usual
no matter who who gets in
so um how
how
how is how is it
feasible we've obviously seen an attack
on short sellers
between the chat rooms and the reddits
uh
but if if you had to if you had to pick
your poison
would you would you write a report and
then cover shorts as the news came out
or
would you
write a report and
follow it all the way down
well first of all we don't write reports
so so we're not you know we're not a
so-called activist short selling shop we
run money
um you know i post things from time to
time on twitter or whatever but
but we don't publish research reports
with the idea of
you know widely disseminating our views
um
and and that's
that's just us that's been uh we've been
in business for 36 years
um
and so
i think that that's number one number
two
um you know the whole the whole
attacking short sellers is a little
you know as i wrote at the time during
the gamestop frenzy it's it's a little
perplexing right um short sellers were
the ones run over here and and
so short sellers have been the victims
um not the evil
geniuses uh that the the the retail
crowd is making them out to be um you
know if you look at gamestop or amc or
any other sort of meme stocks they're
all still up a ton in 2021
and arguably trading way above their
fundamental value so um
you know it's a little bit
watching watching the retail crowd
you know i've dubbed them you know the q
anon of wall street because they just
everything is a conspiracy theory
everything is dark pools naked shorting
uh you know the the regulators in bed
with hedge funds i mean you know and and
it's just fanciful and and
uh when you try to point this out to
people um they they you know they'll
just tell your part of conspiracy and
you're part of the thing too and
meanwhile the conspiracy is a pretty
pretty
weak conspiracy given that we've all
been you know in these kinds of names
that they're talking about the the the
bears have been run over
so again this whole thing is just sort
of paradoxical and makes no sense um but
it really it it really does like tap
into a nerve i think for a lot of
particularly
neophyte investors
who don't
understand the markets
and how they work to just say well it's
it's they it's them
and that's that's a long long-held
psychological you know uh observation
where when you can't explain something
uh it's it's it's they
that are the cause of you you know
overpaying for your out of the money
call options
so you know i i saw a report a few days
ago that the short interest in tesla was
down to 1.9 percent and you know
that was
incredible to me i mean every time you
hear a statistic come out and now it's
trillion dollar market company blah blah
blah how has i just i
how do you wrap your head around the
tesla phenomena
well we you know and we have a put
position
we have about a 1 foot position in the
state
so uh so i get it um look every bull
market has one or two stocks that that
people pin their hopes and dreams on way
beyond the actual reality of what's
happening on the ground
and i went through this at aol in the
late 90s we we had a 10x move against us
at aol because i was convinced aol was
an accounting fraud and and you know it
turned out to be exactly that i just
except time warner bought it for merged
with it for 100 billion
first and and then found out the hard
way
um but even if you go back you know for
a real company like cisco
uh which was sort of the hardware
darling of the dot-com era
and and uh you know people projected
onto cisco not only their existing
growth rates and profitability but the
fact that cisco would become ubiquitous
to the hardware would be making
uh not just routers
but all kinds of things
uh in the hardware space that would be
needed to build out the internet
and
uh if you look at a stock price chart of
cisco it also went parabolic in late 99
early 2000 way beyond its fundamental
value
because it became a hoax and dream stock
and uh and and of course cisco by and
large
delivered on expectations over the next
four or five years but the strong stock
dropped 80 or 90 percent
and and and that's kind of what tesla
feels like at this point in the cycle um
it's not worth a trillion dollars you
you can't get there
but it's become a hopes of dream stock
that you can't disprove
it will be in space travel it will be in
energy
you know
generation and storage it will be an ai
it will be in autonomous driving
and it will do all these things
meanwhile if you
look at tesla it's a car company if you
spread it out against all of the the
the oems the other oems the numbers look
exactly like the other auto oems it's a
car company
speaking of market darlings and
uninformed investors
let's shift gears to cryptocurrency
because
when i'm when i'm you know in the uber
or the lyft and i'm headed to this
airport or that and and anybody i ever
asked well what do you do i said well
you know i'm in economics and finance
i get one of two questions i get asked
about tesla or cryptocurrency
and my
my stock answer that's a coincidence
that someone showed me recently the
correlation between the two is like 0.9
oh my gosh well now that makes a lot of
sense uh but but you know my stock
answer is until there's an international
framework
uh around cryptocurrency in general and
a better understanding in the regulatory
community i don't know that i can answer
the question as to what the future of
cryptocurrency is i look at it more as
kind of a go-go momentum asset class
yeah
and and i would agree it's it's an asset
it's not a currency
it doesn't it doesn't fit most of the
the criteria
for the use as a currency
um you know i get asked by my students
all the time and one of the things i i
urge them to do
is to dig a little deeper on one of our
favorite characters in my class who was
uh a guy by the name of john law who was
the man behind the mississippi scheme in
paris
in uh in
1716 to 1720 bankrupted an already
bankrupt country
but john wall was also one of the
greatest economic thinkers of all time
he was one of the first guys way ahead
of others
to think about the concept of utility of
money and fiat and and
and
he actually put out a really
groundbreaking pamphlet back in
1703 or five on money and trade
considered
and uh you know a lot of economists
consider it you know one of one of the
great economic treatises of all time
and in it he talked about his his
ideas about fiat currency and why
the modern state
should embrace fiat
and everybody knew the downsides of fiat
back then you know the kings and queens
have been clipping the edges of coins
for for centuries
nobody trusted paper money
but he made some interesting
observations that i think have a lot of
relevance for the crypto debate um
because crypto is really anti-fiat at
the end of the day at least that's what
its supporters claim
and and law pointed out that that fiat
um
had
had some inherent advantages
particularly in times of stress and
uncertainty not only could could the
state enforce fiat through the use of
taxation enforcement and the military
and the police and you know all the
instruments of the modern state
but that in times of trouble what we
would call a bear market or or fear
the state also could adjudicate fraud
and and uh and clear transactions and my
my way of reading that was to say the
state could basically also offer you
deposit insurance
and and so all the things that you that
that people
laugh about with fiat and why they're
getting away from fiat money printing
and all the rest of that stuff we know
um
paradoxically is actually i think
making it making the speculative
environment greater which is leading to
appreciation of cryptocurrencies number
one and number two
um you know completely goes out the
window
when people start losing money and then
on top of it start getting defrauded and
realize there's no recourse to anybody
in the crypto land
and say what you want
but but an awful lot of people who want
to uh you know get out of the stock
market put their money in the bank after
they've taken a licking
at least know their money is good in a
bank i'm not so sure it's going to be
good in a lot of the crypto exchanges
and we've already seen that in the bull
market where we've seen instances of
fraud
and and where coins are are lost or
stolen and there's no recourse
and so
it has
there are there are basic inherent
advantages
particularly in times of stress
and fear
and bear markets
to to having a state currency and having
a state state central bank uh that in
bull markets everybody says ah who needs
them um
and so i i just warned my students to go
back and read john law it's it's it's a
it's an interesting paradox that uh that
one of the greatest early economic
thinkers on monetary uh uh utilization
and utility is also one of the greatest
financial criminals of all time um
but
you know i think people have to sort of
think about what it is they're buying
what crypto represents and what it and
what it represents a contra bet against
and i think that that forgetting the
fact that the chart goes up and to the
right
most you know thoughtful crypto balls
will give you a long you know a long
thought piece on why fiat is doomed and
why you have to have limitations and so
on and so forth and most of that flies
right out of the window when people
start losing money
yeah indeed indeed
i wasn't really planning on asking you
this question uh but what what what is
your view on
gold i don't have a view on gold
well then i shouldn't have asked you the
question
no it's it is it's just uh
not in my world i i've bought an awful
lot of it
not for monetary investment purposes
down through the years but uh but that's
more on the social side than the
financial side so uh
we'll uh we'll punt on this question i
fully respect that and i i can tell you
that there's been a lot of carbon in my
life as well but i'm not a carbon
investor myself so um so touche on that
so so telecoms
headed into
uh 1998 long-term capital management
bailout fed put
but telecoms was a sector that you had
identified
are there any
or is there one
sector right now that you see
that is is ripe for
a decline
when eventually this market turns is
there one sector that stands out to you
that's not necessarily uh
a usual suspect
when it comes to saying these stocks are
overview
is there something less more nuanced
that we're not looking at and i'm
talking about an entire sector
right yeah um so i i think that uh
a couple of areas
that i would sort of warn people i i i'm
scratching my head still uh at
commercial real estate cap rates
um you know particularly offices i i you
know we can argue until the cows come
home i will work from home be permanent
um you know what will office
utilizations be
uh
will we need all the space
um
but but right now
uh you have cap rates in the commercial
real estate uh arena because of where
interest rates are
that are just at eye topically low
levels meaning multiples are just
staggeringly high levels
and so there's there's lots of asset
classes that i think are a lot more
turbocharged
than investors think to to uh real to
out uh
interest rates
uh both positively and negatively and i
think commercial real estate is one of
them um
because uh you know with with people
paying four percent cap rates for urban
office buildings i'm just looking at
them and going yeah that's before cap x
that just is insane to me uh if you if
you use 50-year life which is kind of
typical for a building
you're paying two percent cap rates uh
you know uh when the the ten years at
one point six
um
and and is a highly liquid you know the
asset and you've got a building you
can't move that can be taxed to kingdom
come
so i there's that's an area that we're
concerned about um that i would worry
about when a lot of people have assets
the other one that scares the hell out
of me and i i allocate capital as well
as invested i sit on some investment
committees and i've been kind of
sounding the alarm
for lornly now for a few years
i just think that that the embracing of
private equity
um you know to the detriment of public
equity uh or other alternatives uh i
think is is
going to by almost definition be
disappointing um you know you have you
have we consider what the private equity
business model is
um it's it's buying assets
uh
either taking the private or in the
private market
uh at multiples that are at all-time
highs now with interest rates at
all-time lows
um and and exit
possibilities of at wide open
and i think almost all those things have
to stay and remain exactly where they
are today
to continue to have you know the hope
for returns that private equity is
promising but here's the problem and
i've had i've looked at this at some of
the portfolios that i'm on the
committees on and that is if you look at
more recently the returns of private
equity
net of fees they haven't equaled
or they've just equaled
public stock market indices
so you are getting basically the same
thing as an index fund
but much much more illiquid and much
more leveraged and i keep asking the
question that if we're buying private
equity because they're leveraging up to
buying corporate assets why aren't we
earning 2x or 3x the s p
why are we content to earn 100 basis
points above or 100 points below
and that's a head scratcher for me and
hedge funds have faced the same problem
over the past
10 years
uh hedge funds feast did post the dot
com era but really have struggled to to
produce alpha as a group since then yep
and
and you know consequently have seen you
know a relative basis that the the aum
uh mean less um to the detriment of
venture capital and private equity but
private equity is a head scratcher for
me um i i just i'm puzzled
by how easily it's embraced without
people asking the right questions if you
own leveraged equity at a time in which
interest rates have come down to almost
zero
you know why haven't you beaten the
stock market by not as i said under 200
basis points but why haven't you beaten
the stock market by 2x right no i
couldn't agree more in fact
as as you're sitting here describing
this
uh you know
public pensions it seems like the more
underfunded they are the greater their
exposure to private equity and at the
same time
you know i i follow residential real
estate very closely but as a parallel to
your to your office cap rate uh private
equity has been piling into multi-family
high-rises and multi-family cap rates
are even lower than that of office
yeah it's kind of crazy and and uh
and again i mean i just everybody's
operating very comfortably on the idea
the interest rates will never go up
i mean even if we just normalized
interest rates to economic activity for
getting inflation
we probably should be a lot higher than
1.6 on the 10-year
and and you know a couple hundred basis
points move on on rates would just
destroy
real estate valuations given where they
are right now and i just don't get it
and and and so uh that's one area the
private equity conundrum is certainly
another that i think more people
big picture should think through
so uh my last question is uh is is
you've been called the financial sheriff
um
if if if you were to give uh
if it's your final lecture of your fall
or your spring semester and and you're
parting guidance to your students
about uh about forensic accounting and
about sniffing out fraud what what would
your final bit of wisdom be uh to those
students and and to anybody watching
today
in terms of the role that short selling
should play
yeah i mean so uh exactly i mean i've
i've long flipped that that short
sellers are financial detectives and
regulators uh uh our financial
regulators are
financial archaeologists they'll tell
you what happened you know 10 years
after you've lost all your money
and i think that that we want to have a
group in the free market that is
incentivized to ferret out this stuff in
real time and i've told congress that
i've told anybody that that that if
we're going to embrace a free market
system
and and we're going to try to allocate
capital so it doesn't end up in the
hands of of the fraudsters
you need a group of people that are
incentivized to actually you know go
look for it because the regulators won't
get it in in real time they never have
and so uh you you really do need
journalists as well as short sellers and
actors like that
performing in the marketplace to uh to
to
root this stuff out and i think that's a
really important role and should not be
forgotten
well jim i i i can't agree anymore
i mean you're effectively the
whistleblowers uh for the stock market
and and whistleblowers obviously have a
place you know you look you look back uh
and and i just i want to take my hat off
to myself i didn't ask you about enron
and i'm not going to uh
but what is your anniversary
20th anniversary wow
so many of my friends who graduated in
1996 went off to enron and i kept saying
to them i i still can't understand
their their business model and nor could
nor could the people who are going to
work for them explain it to me so
anyways
water under the bridge uh jim i really
really appreciate you taking all this
time today i've learned so much and i'd
love to love to revisit in a year or so
and and look back on on this
unprecedented era uh in in financial
market history
it was my pleasure danielle anytime
thanks take care
bye-bye guys
well i i hope you found uh visiting with
jim chinos as fascinating as i did if
you want to think of him as kind of on
the opposite end of the spectrum of
warren buffett who buys a stock and and
holds it for its life you know he he is
as he described himself he he is a a
financial detective and and and he
rightly points out the critical role of
short selling in the financial markets
and i hope you appreciate his views
i was particularly intrigued with his
views on commercial real estate private
equity if you're interested in some some
things that are also not on the market's
radar screen i recently interviewed
dennis mcgill of zellman associates and
he brought up some interesting
interesting intriguing findings on
demographics that i think you'll find a
great accompaniment to uh the visit that
we've just had with jim chanos so and if
you haven't subscribed please do so
watch that mcgill interview and until
the next time this is danielle dimartino
booth with down the middle thank you
[Music]
you